thor loving thunder
we leave for the premiere in one hour so
we're going to shoot the last of the
things we can show you our reactions for
because it would be a total and utter
lie to then do reactions here
and when we've already seen the movie
but keep a lookout for uh when we're ate
when the embargo lifts i don't know when
it looks so much july 5th so wow we got
some time it's gonna be a lot of
skipping subscribe and click that
notification bell again if i want to
review for that is up we're gonna watch
three clips today now normally we drop
these into final cut and just watch them
back to back all at once but we're gonna
like watch them one at a time talk for
like one to two minutes and watch the
next one so there's video chapters if
there's a specific clip you want to see
a reaction to we're going to kick this
off here with thor love and thunder
official extended clip come to daddy is
what it's called let's get to it and
leave a like while you're at it
[Music]
through the shadow realm how do you know
the atmosphere there has a darkness like
no other this is if color feels to trade
it's unmistakable
well then if it's color we need
let's bring the rainbow
walking the rainbow is that catchphrase
or something she's only gonna throw for
a minute i mean saving lives she's quite
good at but the rest of it she needs
work how many catchphrases have there
been a lot
yup
jumped the gun hang on he moves through
shadows and he's going to the shadow
realm it seems like that's where he's
going to be the most powerful you're
right we can't just go marching in there
it could be a trap are you thinking what
i think you're thinking i'm thinking it
what are we thinking thinking we're
taking it too
what oh but i missed it yeah i didn't
catch that so that's the ex-girlfriend
is it
the old ex-girlfriend judy foster gene
[Laughter]
let's get jody foster cameo yeah
must be hard for you to see your
ex-girlfriend and your ex hammer hanging
out and getting on so well
[Laughter]
what a personality they've given me near
[Laughter]
no
way
i was just calling you
that was funny oh
that was funny i love how uh jane foster
the existence of her is messing so much
with his ego it's not just like oh my
ex-girlfriend's back she's powerful and
i'm kind of longing for her and i'm
attracted to her again as we saw in that
trailer when he's like it's been eight
years and whatever thing he says eight
years seven months and six days give or
take yeah i love uh like how she seems
to be stealing the show whenever she's
in the room like she's the center of
attention and i like how they're really
creating personalities because
stormbreaker was created in uh infinity
war but now taika ytd gets to play with
it and gets to play with the
relationship between stormbreaker and
meonair and then watch how that affects
like the intimate relationship of thor
and jane i think that's really funny
yeah no absolutely it's it's like your
ex-girlfriend came back got your old job
and is now doing it better than you it's
like you have that sort of old flame
combined with oh but she's also kind of
stepping on my actual territory you know
like i bet there's an interesting
emotional conflict to come out of that i
think it'll be fun to see i also really
love the humor of jane just trying to
find a catchphrase and hopefully she
lands on one by the end of this movie
it's gonna be good all right guys so now
we got um we got two more clips got a
thunder milliner's new powers but milner
new powers there was like a 15 second
one that released at mtv this is like a
minute long version of it now so let's
see what's in store starting with me on
their new powers
[Music]
those are the berserkers
that's freaking like xenomorphs
[Music]
cool
that's pretty badass
[Music]
oh cool
whoa holy crap
oh my god
nice that is brilliant upgrade
[Music]
ooh
[Music]
that's great excuse me
oh that was brilliant so cool what a
cool choice
brilliant i'm loving how
it's not even
this relationship is more about he's
jealous of her milner he says
yeah mr clemson seems to be way more
about how he's he's envious of that
your and your best friend are dating now
how does that affect your life that is
so freaking funny and how it seems like
there's a kind of a tension between them
over it yeah it's so hilarious a bit of
that awkwardness between him and mjolnir
just as much as there is between him and
jane it's beautiful oh that's fantastic
i love how you know with the milner
being broken and now reassembled and now
that actually is an upgrade for a
millionaire to be able to disperse into
separate scattered pieces but then
attack multiple what i'm assuming are
the berserkers right here which uh look
terrifying damn that's a lot scarier
than i expected that well it was a great
upgrade on the like we've seen a couple
of these shots so many times and so to
get that extra ounce of all the action
in between that new you know the new
ability to use the sort of kitsune of
mjolnir but also yeah just the
monstrousness of ripping the berserkers
apart with all the fragments like it was
a cool usually you know you get like a
shot or two more and cool it breathes a
little better but this was like oh wow
this is even more badass than it looked
exactly yeah all right last clip called
god of thunder let's check it out
god of thunder king khan
you have finally joined our fight well
they say better late than not at
all this is very nice
as you know we used to live in the
peaceful of us
but in our gods were murdered murdered
by god our sacred temple has been left
unguarded
to control of its power it is our most
sacred shrine and it desecrates not for
long
king you can't
tell them what happened here today tell
us the time the thor
drag tag motley crew misfit desperados
turn the tide in the battle and that's
their names in history the odds may be
against us but i'll tell you hurry here
we go
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's beautiful
oh you know it was my favorite part
about that whole clip is
every time we see
star-lord and thor it seems like
star-lord is kind of like pissy when it
comes to thor and is frustrated but i
liked how you know like he wasn't
showing it to thor but he actually
seemed pumped for thor yeah
like here he comes and he was saying it
along with him like this is a badass
yeah
yeah maybe there'll be some kind of
shift in peter quill where he's actually
kind of fanboying out over thor now
instead of trying to compete with him
all the time
ah that makeup is pretty good on these
people i don't know these people are
no but it's cool it gives it that kind
of star trekkie like oh you know other
culture out in space you know different
culture of gods and different sort of
society being intervened upon and saved
by thor we will explore for a minute
will you be their new god one minute of
exploring
all right guys well that's the last of
the clips we can watch i mean we can
watch the rest but um it just doesn't
feel right it'll just be us going it's
better in the movie though
but thank you guys so much for being
here and keep a look out for when our
review for thor 11 thunders up we will
shoot that at the theater
yeah see you guys